[Music]
we don't know about you but here are the
things we really like shark that's why
it makes us kind of sad that their
numbers are in decline we want to raise
a bit of awareness so we're telling you
about what would happen if these giants
of the Seas disappeared stay watching to
the end to check out some of the best
known sharks in popular culture if you
haven't visited the things before then
please take a moment to give this video
a thumbs up and hit the subscribe button
today we're gonna show you that this is
what happens if all sharks disappeared
the end of an era if sharks disappeared
from the planet we would lose more than
400 million years of the species being
inexistent to put it another way there
were sharks on earth before there were
trees that's right
seems pretty unbelievable but it's true
the first thing we could recognize as a
tree
the Archaeopteryx first grew where the
Sahara Desert is now around 350 million
years ago even then it wouldn't have
looked quite as much like the trees that
we know today that's because its leaves
were different to current one they
looked a lot like what we would now know
as fern the plant's name even means
ancient fern in Latin there was another
big difference between Archaeopteryx and
the plants we know today the prehistoric
plant didn't reproduce by planting seeds
but instead it distributed spores but at
first glance the Archaeopteryx would
definitely have been recognizable as a
tree even 350 million years ago however
the first thing we could call a shark
first appeared 400 million years ago
again though these would not have been
quite the same as the creatures that we
know today for instance a lot of them
would have had short rounded heads
rather different to modern-day shark and
its tail would have been rather more
symmetrical to what we know now however
it would have had jaws replaceable teeth
toothed like scales and paired fins
which all define the shark so who would
want to lose so much Natural History hey
guys we are so excited to announce we're
producing
our own original content head over to
the trendy for the best DIYs fashion
tips makeup hacks and so much more we
are sure you're going to love it and be
sure to let us know what you think in
the comment section let me hear from you
see you there
unbalancing the ecosystem one of the
things that everyone knows about sharks
is that they are the supreme apex
predators of the ocean that means that
while they eat other sea creatures
there's nothing in the water that eats
them
this means they play a crucial role in
the oceanic ecosystem they help to
remove the weak and sick creatures while
they keep the balance with other species
of shark to make sure there is diversity
now we all know of the beauty and rarity
of the coral reefs that exist in the
ocean when the sharks have been killed
off the reefs have declined there's a
reason why that is it's because when
there are no sharks other predatory fish
that sharks keep under control
eat the herbivore fish with fewer of
them macro algae grows meaning the coral
can no longer compete with it in turn
that means the micro system that has
grown up around the coral reef turns
into one that supports macro algae that
means that the coral reef slowly dies
and that's definitely bad why well coral
reefs are some of the most diverse
natural habitats on planet Earth
although they cover less than 1/10 of 1%
of the oceans floor they are home to
around 25 percent of the world's marine
wildlife so imagine the devastation that
would cause changing your menus when
sharks patrol the waters what they eat
is important their diet helps keep
things in check and the diversity of
life in balance a decline in the number
of sharks in one part of the world has
had one specific kind of impact in the
North Atlantic off the eastern coast of
the United States there has been a
dwindling of the number of sharks
because they've been dying off one of
their main sources of food rays have
been increasing one of the things that
Rays eat the most is the qua hog which
is a type of clam it's the clam that is
a key ingredient in clam chowder
the iconic New England suit this is
something that is sold in hundreds of
restaurants along the coast in states
like Rhode Island New Hampshire Maine
and Massachusetts people will take a
trip to the seaside purely to have a
delicious and tasty bowl of the stuff
however if there are fewer of the
bivalves then that means that there will
be less clam chowder made so that means
that restaurants are either having to
raise their prices or worse yet for
gourmets
the food off the menu and that has
another knock-on effect with less clam
chowder for sale fewer and fewer
day-trippers and holiday makers are
heading off to the coast farewell to
scallops the scallop is one of the more
interesting kinds of shellfish around
even if you don't know what a scallop is
you'll know what its shell looks like
it's the classic shell design round with
a straight bit at the bottom have you
ever seen the logo of a Shell gas
station it's that but did you know that
sharks help keep scallops alive that's
because they eat bull rays which eat
scallops when the number of sharks in
the North Atlantic Ocean declined
back in 2007 that's what happened the
bull Rays weren't stopped from eating
the scallops so the number of scallops
collapse if you're a fan of seafood
you'll know that scallops are pretty
delicious they've got a nice texture
respond well to seasoning and can even
go together with meat to create a
high-end kind of surf and turf meal but
the shells themselves sometimes have a
higher meaning in Europe in the Middle
Ages pilgrims would take the long and
arduous journey to the shrine of
Santiago de Compostela in northern Spain
as a sign that they have visited the
holy site people would wear a scallop
shell that is because of a legend that
says Saint James
whose relics are at the shrine once
rescued a knight who is covered in
scallops and the tradition continues to
this day imagine if people were unable
to carry on a medieval tradition global
warming on the rise today when we talk
about what could happen if there were no
more sharks we will be talking about a
comparatively small selection of the
animals that are kept in the seas by
them but it isn't just the creatures in
the seed that are protected by the
oceans apex predator no it's the entire
planet itself
that's because sharks actually help
defend against global warming in 2016
researchers from the Dept of life and
Environmental Sciences at Bournemouth
University in the United Kingdom
discovered that overfishing of the Seas
and especially the slaughter of sharks
was causing temperatures to rise when
sharks and other top predators are taken
away from the marine ecosystem that
naturally leads to more and more of the
creatures that they prey on as a result
they give out more and more carbon
dioxide and because of that temperatures
can get dangerously hot which affects
all life on planet Earth the study's
co-author Elizabeth Spears said this
study really identified sharks as a
crucial part of marine
ecosystem and not the frightening
creatures that they are sometimes
portrayed as dr. Rick Stafford who led
the research that people needed to be
more aware of the marine ecosystem and
how it affects everyone and everything
the team said negative reports on shark
attacks along with a lack of knowledge
of the environment of the sea led to
limited public support for marine
conservation economic collapse as we
will see today the way in which sharks
help maintain the balance of nature in
the ocean is very useful we can see them
as a guard that prevents things getting
too out of hand it is thanks to the way
sharks operate that we're able to take a
lot of the fish that we like to eat and
not worry about the ocean stock of them
getting depleted that has to be a good
thing right but it's not just about what
we like to eat without the shark to help
keep things good in the ocean the sea
stocks of fish would run out pretty
quickly and that wouldn't just mean that
some of us would end up having to change
our dietary habit no a lot of people
would end up having no work at all the
United Nations Food and Agriculture
Organization estimates that there are 38
million commercial fishermen and fish
farmers across the world not only that
but there are 500 million people in the
economically less developed world alone
who depend in one way or another
unfinished on fishing in the sea so if
all the Sharks would disappear the
world's economy would go into absolute
meltdown and utter chaos
save the hammerhead in our video today
we're looking at some of the types of
animals that sharks help to conserve
however we also think that there are
some sharks that we really miss anyway
if they weren't there anymore one of
those is one of the most distinctive and
instantly recognizable creatures in the
world's oceans
that's the hammerhead shark once you see
it you know exactly what it is as you
can probably guess it's the shark whose
head kind of looks like a hammer
having said that did you know that
there's no such thing as a single
species of hammerhead shark that's
because there are actually nine types of
sharks that fit into that category
there's the bonnethead and the scalloped
bonnet heads as well as the Carolina
scalloped great small eye and smooth
hammerheads there's also the scoop head
and the winged head sharks these are all
separate species however they all have
the distinctive skull shape in common
the reason why they've evolved seas is
because it actually
helps them to find their prey in the
darkness of the ocean that's because
their sensory organs are spread out over
a wider area they've also got something
unique called the ampullae of Lorenzini
please help them detect the electrical
fields generated by some kinds of rays
which the Hammerhead eat considering the
rays often bury themselves in the sand
the ampullae are useful and who would
want to see such an interesting animal
disappear from the earth goodbye to the
minnows if you think of a shark we'd bet
that you think of something that's
gigantic and kind of intimidating but
not all sharks are massive Giants of the
deep in fact there are some sharks that
might be smaller than the screen you're
watching this video on right now did you
know that the world's smallest species
of shark is the dwarf lanternshark the
biggest of these can grow is just over
eight inches it lives in the tropical
Atlantic Ocean just off the coast of
Venezuela and Colombia and they aren't
the most deadly creature to put it
mildly their main diet is krill but
there's something really cool about them
because they live in the depths of the
ocean they're able to illuminate
themselves so they can trap their prey
Lantern sharks are pretty common but
because they live at such low depth they
haven't been studied that much other
species include the Green Lantern shark
which grows to ten inches and the
African Lantern shark which grows to 11
inches there's other small sharks -
these usually live low down near the sea
floor with the pale cat shark only ever
having been caught one from this one
catch though
scientists were able to find out that it
lays egg and it also measures around
eight point five inches there may well
be other species of tiny shark that we
don't know about wouldn't it be a shame
if they just disappeared no more giant
the classical image of a shark is one of
power strength Grace and size these are
the creatures that dominate the Seas and
reign as apex predators
now while the sheer diversity of sharks
is such that there are plenty of smaller
sharks there's certainly some truth to
the idea of the shark as an oceanic
giant the largest shark in the world
today is the whale shark this giant
creature is also the largest kind of any
fish on planet Earth
the biggest one studied measured 42 feet
in length for comparison that's the size
of a school bus but despite being
gigantic the whale shark is a pretty
peaceful kind of shark it's a filter
feeder which means it eats fish
naturally as it swims along but it has a
massive now measuring around 4 feet in
width and it has more than
and teeth but it can't bite or chew that
definitely isn't true when it comes to
the world's largest predatory shark
though that's the legendary great white
shark this creature can grow up to 26
feet in length they are extremely
powerful swimmers and can reach speeds
of up to 15 miles per hour and their
teeth are incredibly powerful a great
white shark can have as many as 300 of
them minutes now so you can see even the
biggest shark show remarkable diversity
sharks in popular culture today we've
been looking at what would happen if all
the sharks in the world suddenly
disappeared but here's a question for
you what would happen if 400 million
years ago sharks had never even evolved
that sounds a little bit far-fetched
they've managed to survive for gigantic
extinction events after all but bear
with us think of all the different
strands of popular culture that you
would never have experienced one of the
most famous sharks in all of pop culture
is of course the eponymous maneater in
Jaws this thrilling film released in
1976 was the movie that pretty much
instantly catapulted Steven Spielberg
into the top leagues of movie directors
and despite the shark being far more
dangerous than any real-world equivalent
could be it certainly generated an
interest in a generation
indeed the tales of deadly sharks ended
up becoming a cliche but the shark in
Jaws is one we look at fondly a
friendlier shark is the one in Finding
Nemo
he's called Bruce which is also the name
people who worked on jaws called their
mechanical shark he doesn't want to eat
the main characters at that Disney
classic telling them fish are friends
not food which became one of the
naughties oddest catchphrases we could
go on and on but we think it would be a
shame if these characters had never
crossed our consciousness that's all for
this is what happens if all sharks
disappeared if you liked it then you
should check out 20 Chinese knockoffs
that are actually better than the
original thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]